direction à présent la nouvelle maison
de la justice et du droit de tour vous
avez un problème familial un litige avec
votre employeur ou votre propriétaire
vous êtes victime d'une infraction
pénale mais vous vous demandez comment
être bien informé de vos droits la
maison de la justice et du droit
peut-être une solution aujourd'hui les
nouveaux locaux de cet établissement ont
été inaugurés ils sont à tour au 7
maille georgebc sur place les
consultations juridiques sont anonymes
et confidentielles elles sont
accessibles gratuitement à toutes et à
tous Roméo
marm
des conseils juridiques gratuits donnés
par des professionnels anciennement
installé à jouer les tours depuis 1999
la seule maison de justice et du droit
du département d'indrloire à déménager à
tour située près des rives du Cher elle
a été installée dans une ancienne maison
de santé prêté par la ville et rénové
pour l'occasion c'est environ 20000 €
pour les fluites 25000 € pour ce qui
aurait pu être valorisé en terme de
location et puis nous avons investi
aussi pour adapter les locaux et
accueillir comme il se doit cette C
maison de de la justice et du droit et
là c'est 160000 € que la ville a
déboursé le lieu propose un accueil
gratuit et confidentielle sous
l'autorité de la procureur de la
République et de la présidente du
tribunal judiciaire de tour alors la MJD
fait partie du réseau des points justice
les points justice ce sont des lieux où
le conseil départemental de l'accès au
droit délivre une information en matière
d'accès au droit donc c'est un lieu
parmi d'autres
en effet une quinzaine d'établissements
dans le département d'indréloire
proposent des conseils juridiques et un
accueil physique mais la MJD est le seul
lieu de ce type à être le prolongement
du tribunal judiciaire si délégué du
procureur et une greffière travaille ici
pour rendre la justice accessible voilà
donc le procureur c'est un peu il a un
peu un rôle de garde triage donc il
identifie les procédures qui sont graves
ou alors qui sont commises par des
délinquants un peu chevronnés et donc il
oriente ça vers le tribunal
correctionnel ce qui semble un petit peu
moins grave ou alors des fait qui ont
été commis par par quelqu'un qui n'a pas
déjà été condamné on Orient plutôt en
alternative aux poursuitite et pour
obtenir des informations juridiques sans
bouger de chez soi il vous reste une
option appelz le